the world prepares for judge Brett
Kavanaugh and his accuser to testify in
front of the Senate President Trump
prepares to release the FISA Kraken and
we analyze the latest poll results i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
oh man I didn't mention that stormy
Daniels has now described the presidents
junk so we have to get to that also
today because I mean come on how could
we ignore that on Erev Yom Kippur the
Day of repentance we have to get in a
little bit of last-minute frippery
before we actually start the repentance
that is happening tonight also I do want
to let you know just right up front that
we do have a special that is beginning
on Fox News this coming Sunday the Ben
Shapiro election special so that is
coming the next four weeks on Fox we are
really excited to bring you that it
should be a lot of fun and have special
guests we're gonna be analyzing the news
when you're going through the polls it's
gonna be just great it's 8 p.m. on
Sundays so go check that out on Sunday
that will be our first episode very
pumped up about that before we get to
any of the other news let me mention to
you that there's no reason for you to
continue to rack up enormous sums of
credit card debt instead with Lending
Club you can consolidate your debt or
pay off credit cards with one fixed
monthly payment since 2007 Lending Club
has helped millions of people regain
control of their finances with
affordable fixed-rate personal loans no
trip to a bank no high interest credit
cards just go to Lending Club com tell
them about yourself how much you want to
borrow pick the terms that are right for
you if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform over
thirty five billion dollars in loans
issued just check it out at Lending Club
com
slash Ben you can check your rate in
minutes you can borrow up to 40 grand
that's Lending Club com / Ben Lending
Club comm / Ben all loans made by web
bank member FDIC Equal Housing lender go
check them out right now because again
there's no reason for you to rack up
enormous credit card charges if you
don't pay off your credit card bill that
sucker can grow really fast on you why
wouldn't you just consolidate your debt
go check it out at Lending Club com /
Ben again that's Lending Club com / Ben
to check your rate in just minutes
alrighty so the world waits aghast as we
find out more about the accusations
against Judge Brett Kavanaugh Brett
Kavanaugh of course president films pick
to replace Justice Anthony Kennedy on
the Supreme Court and he was considered
the establishment pick let us recall I
had serious questions about judge Brett
Kavanaugh on policy grounds but there
seemed to be no real question about him
on character grounds this is a Catholic
father of multiple girls this is a guy
who had been very active in his
community this is somebody who coached
his girls bath
ball team and now there's an accuser who
has come forward her name is Christine
Ford and she has come forward and she
suggests that back when Brett Kavanaugh
was 17 years old and she was 15 years
old at an unspecified party an
unspecified date at an unspecified
location he lay on top of her tried to
rip off her bathing suit covered her
head her hand her mouth with his hand in
an attempt to stifle her screams and
then somehow she escaped and that's the
accusation and they're a bunch of things
to be noted about this accusation first
of all he was 17 at the time and she was
15 according to her this is why it's
good to go to juvenile court when stuff
like this happens because for a lot of
juvenile crimes these the record time
this sort of thing would be sealed right
I mean we wouldn't we have a general
presumption with regard to teenagers
that teenagers are to be granted a
little bit more leeway now listen I'm
not somebody who actually likes that
argument a whole heck of a lot depending
on the nature and severity of the crime
I think there are a lot of cases in
which teens ought to be tried as adults
we talk about rape or murder but in this
particular case the FBI was told about
this and they can't even check it out
because there is no alleged crime that
has taken place like they don't even
know what alleged crime would rise to
the federal level as I mentioned
yesterday and they have no facts to go
on here and she has no facts that she
has provided that would actually allow
for a specific investigation of what
exactly happened over here and what's
even worse her lawyers are now basically
attempting to prevent her from from
saying anything of interest about it her
own lawyer said that it's not important
for her to provide corroboration for her
story her lawyer basically said her name
is Deborah Katz she says basically that
that this woman has no obligation to
probably provide any evidence that these
accusations are even true she can just
throw it out there and we're all
supposed to believe it without any
further corroboration has your client
spoken to any of those other guys or
that girl who could help corroborate her
story she's not and why not is it time
to do that that's that's not her job to
do that if this is going to be
investigated it should be done by
investigators okay well what exactly is
that supposed to mean the FBI can't
investigate she hasn't given any
corroborating details who's supposed to
investigate this and the left is using
the FBI as though they're the super
secret police the FBI is a law
enforcement body tasked with the
enforcement of federal law they are not
the great master detectives
it's not like there's a regular
detective and then there's Sherlock
Holmes and Sherlock Holmes is the FBI
that's not how this thing works it's not
we don't have enough evidence to
actually show something happen but the
FBI they will ferret out the truth it's
funny how the left has come to rely on
the FBI this way as opposed to you know
actually holding hearings on this issue
so yesterday Senator Chuck Grassley
invited the the alleged victim Christine
Blasi Ford invited her to speak in front
of the Senate committee and supposedly
she accepted according to CNN the
Republican leader of the Senate
Judiciary Committee said on Monday he
would convene remarkable new public
hearings in a week's time after sexual
assault allegations emerged against
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
both Cavanaugh and the woman who has
accused him of physical and sexual
assault Christine Blasi Ford will
testify before the panel setting up a
blockbuster event that could decide
Cavanaugh's fate the announcement made
under pressure from lawmakers to fully
examine the new claims will delay what
had been a glide path toward
confirmation for president Trump's
nominee the political stakes for the
White House and members of Congress are
enormous
as the me2 movement galvanizes women
ahead of key congressional elections in
November now make no mistake the only
thing left wants out of this is
withdrawn Kavanagh nomination in the
hopes that somehow for some desperate
reason Democrats will take the Senate in
November and by the time Trump can
nominate somebody else and go through
the process it will be a Democratic
Senate that can reject the nominee
that's the actual plan here it has
nothing to do with Brett Kavanaugh it
has nothing to do with the seriousness
of the charges the Democrats are not
treating the charges seriously
Dianne Feinstein who originally received
these receive these in July she did
nothing for eight weeks for eight weeks
she did nothing nothing she didn't tell
her Senate Democratic colleagues she'd
until the rest of the Senate shouldn't
ask any questions of Cavanaugh in
writing or in person
she never phone call with Cavanaugh she
didn't talk to the lady presumably right
all that happened is that she received
this letter she sat on it and then just
before the confirmation she decided to
release it in a last-ditch attempt to
hold off the hearings as long as
possible so that this would stretch
beyond the next election cycle that's
all that is happening right here and how
do we know that because now it is
obvious that the Democrats are simply
using delay tactics so there's ten
Democrats the Judiciary Committee
Democrats put out a statement yesterday
and they said this with only a few hours
notice and over the objections of
ranking member Feinstein Judiciary
Committee Republicans scheduled a staff
level phone call with Brett Kavanaugh
concerning allegations
sexually assaulted a young woman in view
of the enormity and seriousness of these
allegations a staff only phone call
behind closed doors is unacceptable and
Democratic staff will not participate
this isn't how things should be done and
is in complete violation of how this
committee has worked in the past
the FBI has the resources and know-how
to conduct an objective independent
evaluation of these sensitive
allegations with appropriately trained
investigators this isn't just about an
interview
it's about analyzing information and
gathering the facts that's what the FBI
does and that's why they're in charge of
the background review process except
that the FBI has already kicked this to
the White House they said we have no
basis for investigation here what the
hell are you talking about
so Democrats are throwing this to the
FBI so that they can avoid actually
going forward with hearing that might
clear this up their entire goal is to
smear Brett Kavanaugh whether this woman
is telling the truth or not that is not
relevant to the Democrats the Democrats
in the Senate Judiciary Committee are
obviously engaged in political
brinksmanship here this has nothing to
do with guilt or innocence it has
nothing to do it the truth of the
charges is one of the most scurrilous
political tacks I've ever seen whether
she's telling the truth or not because
Democrats don't actually want to get at
the truth that's what's obvious from
this procedural maneuvering they're not
doing this because they want to know
what actually happened they're not doing
this because they think Brett Kavanaugh
ought to be kicked off because they
believe the charges they're doing this
because they want a delay so that they
can stop whoever Trump nominates that's
all this is this isn't about Cavanaugh
versus Christine Blasi Ford this is
about roe v wade this is about Democrats
want to uphold what they believe to be a
left majority on the Supreme Court now
the irony is that Cavanaugh probably
wouldn't vote to overturn roe v-- wade
in the first place
but that doesn't actually matter for
Democrats it is important they stop
whatever this nomination is the
Democrats continue they say if that
review is closed we call on the FBI to
reopen it and properly investigate this
new important information like based on
what again based on what if you're the
FBI how do you possibly look at charges
that are so unspecific we don't know
date we don't know time we don't know
location we don't know in maybe year or
I mean I guess that the the accusation
is summer of 1982 summer of 1982 in an
unspecified place what does the FBI
supposed to do with that use a time
machine this isn't and this isn't
Minority Report
hey Tom Cruise's in the back room with a
bunch of weird goo people
to figure out what's gonna happen in the
future and prevent future crime that's
not how this works but of course the
Democrats know that this is all a
cynical ploy III do love how Democrats
are playing all of this they say that
she is absolutely believable what makes
her absolutely believable that it's
useful my Barbara Boxer who is just an
idiot former senator from the state of
California she was on MSNBC she was the
stupidest woman in the United States
Senate she's no longer there now it's
Feinstein and Kamala Harris Feinstein is
smart Kamala Harris is not Barbara Boxer
says we should believe this woman why
should you believe this woman well
because we should believe this woman but
why you ask well because we should
there's Barbara Boxer explaining this
woman is to be believed Ana issue is one
of the most incredible people I know in
this world she has a heart of gold and
she's sharp
she knows after sitting with that woman
you can believe Ana issue and you can
believe dr. Ford this was attempted rape
and this is a woman who exhibits dr.
Ford courage but the classic signs of
post-traumatic stress what in the world
yeah again where's the evidence that is
true well the evidence is that she wants
it to be true and we've seen this on
both sides of the aisle right we've seen
that there are folks on the right who
are like oh well I don't believe the Roy
Moore allegations
why don't you believe multiple women
something like eight women who testified
he used to hit on fourteen-year-old
girls what because I don't believe them
but why well because in this particular
case I don't know who to believe right I
don't know who to believe I think there
are holes in her story that need to be
filled I think that the the Democrats
are playing politics with this but
Democrats are all fired sure that this
woman's allegations are real why well
because it's politically convenient
here's Chuck Schumer I think the
allegations of Professor Ford are
extremely credible yeah she took a
lie-detector test she talked to this to
her therapist they were having family
counseling in part because of what
happened to her five years ago and told
all the details and third to come out
and say something like this puts you and
your family through incredible scrutiny
people throw brick bats at you and
everything else she
do it on a whim I don't think she did it
for political reasons so she has a great
deal of credibility okay this is this
argument that a woman has a great deal
of credibility because she has a lot to
lose coming forward who has more to lose
christine Blasi for tor Judd Brett
Kavanaugh who's not only going to lose
his career but also a spot in the
Supreme Court if we're gonna talk about
people who have something to lose and
who are risking a lot here it's
Kavanaugh not Christine Blasi Ford who's
being held up as a heroine for all of
this now I'm not saying emotionally it's
not difficult for her to come forward
and again I'm gonna say it for the 1,000
time it's quite possible she's telling
the truth but I don't know and you don't
know and nobody knows because the only
people in that room even allegedly well
Brett Kavanaugh and Mark charge both of
whom deny and this woman Brett Kavanaugh
by the way says he wasn't even at a
party he says he wasn't even at that
party and the left says well how does he
know which party she's talking about
unless he knows the party well maybe he
wasn't at a party it's pretty blanket
claim I should be easy to debunk if the
Democrats think they can debunk it so
why can't they to bunk it because they
don't feel they needed a bunk it this is
all politics and I'll talk in a minute
about about the lie detector side of
this
well what Chuck Schumer has to say right
there because it's just asinine but
first let's talk about the possibility
of natural disaster so you're watching
tropical depression Florence bad or the
East Coast people who are holed up in
their houses maybe have no place to go
and you hope that everybody is stocked
up you hope that everybody is able to
take care of their family well you
should be one of those people when there
is some sort of disaster no power
refrigeration failing stores closed this
is when it would be good to have some
emergency food on hand I trust my
Patriots apply for dependable food
storage and you should as well every
person in your household should have at
least a two-week emergency food supply
from my Patriot supply this week they're
offering a special price of only 75
bucks for a food kit that contains
ninety two servings of breakfasts
lunches and dinners call eight eight
eight eight oh three 14 13 or go to my
special website prepare with been calm
the food lasts up to 25 years in storage
only 75 bucks that includes a rugged
tote order now 888 803 1413 or prepare
with been calm again that's eight eight
eight eight oh three fourteen thirteen
or prepare with been calm go check it
out right now you should be prepared in
case of emergency your family should be
prepared the government tells you you
ought to be prepared so you should go
check it out right now and make sure
that you are in case god forbid you're
gonna need to use it eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen prepare
with been calm again 75 bucks for ninety
two servings of breakfast lunch
and dinners check it out right now
prepare with been calm so you heard
Chuck Schumer there say that this woman
took a lie-detector test who cares why
detectives are inadmissible in court
they do not actually prove whether
someone is lying or not
according to LiveScience a polygraph is
not a lie detector and it never was a
polygraph detects physiological
expressions associated with lying in
some people such as a racing heart and
sweaty fingers the determination of
truth versus falsehood is a subjective
interpretation by the polygraph examiner
so when people say that there's a they
took a polygraph that doesn't mean
anything it legitimately means nothing
it's not even admissible in court and
you know this is now proof that she's
absolutely telling the truth by the way
she could be telling you the truth
about what she thinks she believes
people people actually over time people
have memories of events that are not
necessarily the most accurate but you
start to believe that that was your
memory of the event because memories
change over time I'm not even accusing
this woman of bad faith all I'm saying
is that if there's no corroborate of
evidence there is no way to suggest that
she is more believable than Brett
Kavanaugh so president Trump responds to
these accusations here's what President
Trump has to say judge Kavanagh is one
of the finest people that I've ever
known he's an outstanding judge
respected by everybody never had even a
little blemish on his record the FBI has
I think gone through a process six times
with him over the years where he went to
higher and higher positions he is
somebody very special okay this is just
it is cynical garbage and how can you
tell that it's cynical garbage the way
the Democrats are playing this again not
the accusation the way the Democrats are
playing it how can you tell it's cynical
garbage listen to Donna Brazile donna
brazile was the head of the DNC briefly
before it turned out that she was
feeding tube eight questions allegedly
to Hillary Clinton against Bernie
Sanders and then she was ousted well
she's still a respected figure in
democratic circles for some odd reason
but here's Donna Brazile explain that
this in a nutshell is why democrats are
doing this democrats are doing this as a
delay tactic they are obvious about it
they are not hiding the ball here is
donna Brazile explaining does that sound
right to you about a one-in-three chance
of winning son absolutely look at the
beginning of this cycle we we thought
that the Republicans would taste 60
seats in the Senate but Democrats are
doing well in
states that Donald Trump won in 2016
Jill Manchin is doing very well so yes
we we're confident not overconfident but
confident that we can run the tables in
the Senate that's what this is about
delay it until they run the table in the
Senate then they have a majority then
they can reject Brett Kavanaugh or
anyone else Trump nominates and keep the
Supreme Court seat open until after 2020
claiming that Trump is under FBI
investigation which he is not and
therefore that President Trump has no
ability to appoint a Supreme Court
justice now listen the Republicans know
what's going on here right Mitch
McConnell knows what's going on here so
the Senate Majority Leader he says
listen it's it's obvious what's
happening here Democrats waited until
the eleventh hour to dump this
allegation specifically an attempt to
scuttle Cavanaugh this is not about
getting to the truth in any real way yet
chose to keep secret until the 11th hour
neither she nor any of her Democratic
colleagues chose to raise this
allegation during the committee staffs
bipartisan background calls with a
nominee all of this is true what what he
is saying and it is absurd the lengths
to which left is going on this when I
say it's absurd
I mean legitimately absurd so now they
have people like Louis
Julia louis-dreyfus signing letters in
support of the accuser what the hell
does the veep star have to do with
anything the answer is nothing the
answer is nothing she signed a letter
signed by 200 women from this woman's
high school who say quote we believe dr.
Blasi Ford and are grateful that she
came forward to tell her story so the
hell what my gardener signed a letter in
favor of Judge Brett Kavanaugh oh my
pool guy signed a letter in favor of
Judge Brent Cavanaugh and what in the
world does Julia Julia Louie Dreyfus
have to do with any of this was she
presents the party nope did she know
Brett Kavanaugh nope she once went to a
high school that this woman also at one
point attended Wow whoo I went to Walter
Reed junior middle school okay if I went
to Walter Reed and somebody else went to
Walter Reed well that means that if I
sign a letter having to do with that
person even if they graduated 20 years
before I went there that means I have
additional credibility on what they did
in a bedroom that I haven't heard of 20
years but 36 years beforehand maybe
before I was born I should do that I
should I went to Harvard Law School any
time
anything happens that is scandalous
about a Harvard Law alum and it happened
before I was born in heav'nly 1955 I
should sign a letter saying I don't
believe this man as an alum of their law
school this is the length to which left
is going and it's it's so absurd that it
may it actually undercuts this woman it
hurts the me2 movement the media
movement was all about the believability
and credibility of women the idea was if
a woman says something we should
initially give it credibility and then
we should go examine the evidence to try
and confirm the story but we shouldn't
dismiss her story out of hand as many
people are sometimes want to do that was
the case of the meaty movement instead
Democrats by cynically using an
accusation that has no corroborating
evidence to this point none okay the
first time this was ever reported to
anyone who is not her husband in 2002
was 2012 30 years after the event
instead of actually holding all of our
accusations and accusers to the same
standard of evidence now the Democrats
are cynically playing politics it is
obvious that they just want to believe
what they want to believe here
the best example that I can spot is from
Anna Marie Cox who was on MSNBC last
night again the fact that anyone takes
Anna Marie Cox seriously is beyond me
but she was on MSNBC last night on
Laurens horizontals show and she
explains it doesn't matter whether
Cavanaugh is guilty or innocent the only
thing that matters is whether in the
hearings he's nice to the woman III I
legitimately cannot make up what she's
about to say here's what she says a
parallel here is that we need to judge
Brett Kavanaugh not just on what he may
or may not have done but how he treats a
woman's pain and that is something I'm
gonna paying attention to on Monday now
I'll give you a spoiler alert I don't
think Brett Kavanaugh takes women's pain
very seriously and I know that because
of the decisions he's made as a judge
but I think that for have that unfold on
national television live and will be
quite instruction instructive I don't
flip people off on this show but you
have no idea how tempted I am to throw
up a double burden at that one I mean
that is just disgusting that's
disgusting so if a woman accuses me like
Ben Shapiro the woman accuses me of rape
and I say she's totally full of crap
this is made up for political purposes
then Anna Marie Cox's question is going
to be do I treat her pain with respect
I'm falsely alleged to have committed
rape or a ten
did rape and I'm supposed to treat that
woman's accusations with her pain with
respect that's how you gonna judge it
and you're going to prejudge how I treat
that woman based on the facts that I
have ruled in the past in ways you don't
like on judicial cases and then you have
the gall to say this isn't a political
maneuver is it a political hit job again
they're undermining this woman when this
first came out I said this woman is not
uncredible I said it yesterday on the
show and now the way the Democrats are
treating this woman makes me think she
is less credible just because of the way
Democrats are treating her things
they're treating her as a political
football that statement for an Anna
Marie Cox is just morally abysmal
morally disreputable disgusting
repulsive repugnant I'm going through
the full thesaurus here Hey
I lose capacity for speech and how
disgusting it is to suggest that if you
are falsely accused of a crime your
activity in feeling the pain of the
person falsely accusing you in your view
is really the main consideration here
not your guilt or innocence doesn't
matter if the person is lying about you
or got it wrong
the only thing that matters is how nice
you are about it when you deny it my god
my god these people and she has no shame
have these people no sense of decency or
shame just unbelievably absurd
unbelievably absurd okay in just a
second I'm gonna get to some more
response by Democrats to all this plus
we'll take a look at the polls and
president Trump says that he is going to
declassify a lot of the Russia gate
materials who will get to all of that
and the Emmy so we have a lot coming up
still on the show but first I want to
talk to you about talk to you about
boosting your energy level and boosting
your cognition we live in a fast-paced
multitasking world that demands quick
thinking you want to be razor sharp on
top of your game all the time and this
is why you ought to be checking out Oh
max cognitive boost it's a game-changing
solution at fuels peak performance at
boost memory focus energy all-around
crystal clear thinking folks in the
office have taken it they've told me
that this really does work for them Oh
max is offering my listeners 70% off a
one-month supply of cognitive boost plus
free shipping and that 60-day money-back
guarantee go - Oh max boost calm slash
Shapiro today take advantage of the
savings that is Om ax boost calm slash
Shapiro for 70% off a one-month supply
cognitive boost directly impacts
physical
mental performance strength agility
cognate you'll feel more awake basically
so if you're ready to optimize your mind
and body's fullest potential then go
check it out Oh max cognitive boost Oh
max boost calm slash Shapiro today get
70% off a one-month supply plus free
shipping and a 60-day money-back
guarantee
that's oh ma xbo OST comm slash capiro
to get a 70% off one month supply free
shipping sixty day money-back guarantee
so if you don't like it you're not gonna
lose any money on it
Oh max boost calm slash a pair of terms
and conditions do apply alright so it's
not just Anna Marie Cox saying something
just morally excruciating ly discussing
there it's also Matthew down so matthew
dowd is the supposed conservative
analyst on ABC political news he's on
their sunday shows a lot and matthew
dowd tweeted out this regarding the
Brett Kavanaugh accusations and this is
why you wonder why the meanto movement
is breaking down what the left has a
tendency to do but the left has a
tendency to do is take issues where we
are unified and then pick cases where
there is not enough evidence for unity
to be to be merited and then claim that
lack of unity on this particular case
demonstrates lack of unity on the
underlying issue here's what I mean the
left will say shooting police shooting
black people in racist fashion is bad
and people on the right go that's of
course of course and then the left will
say Michael Brown was a gentle giant
who's shot in cold blood in the back by
a white police officer and the rail go
well that's not true that's not none of
those things are true and the left will
say you don't take that crime seriously
enough if you took that crime seriously
enough you would believe what I have to
say and this just shows that the
underlying issue you don't care about
you don't care about racist shootings
doesn't matter that you thought that it
was a racist shooting when Walter Scott
was shot in the back in South Carolina
doesn't matter that you think the
falando Casteel shooting was a bad shoot
doesn't matter that you can name off the
top of your head five six police
shootings of people that are racially
suspect at best if you don't agree with
me on this fringe case where the
evidence is not on my side it
demonstrates you don't have any care
about the underlying issue hey that's
the way the left likes to play these
things and they're doing the same thing
with regard to the meat see movement
folks on the right are not in favor of
sexual assault god forbid that's insane
that's insane hey I'm the most sexually
pure person that I have ever heard of in
secular culture in the religious
community okay I'm pretty common but
in the non-religious community I'm a
dude who has had sex with one woman ever
and it's my wife and it was after we
were married and I was 24 and got
married so I'm pretty good about this
stuff
I believe that rapists should be
castrated or killed
I think rape is a worse crime than
murder in many cases I think sexual
abuse is the worst thing you can do to a
human being basically and the
implication is if I have questions about
this woman's account because there's not
enough evidence to verify it that this
means I don't care about sexual assault
that's how the me2 movement falls apart
that's how you take an issue where 90%
of Americans agree and turn it into an
issue or 55 percent of Americans agree
and the left likes to do this the left
wants to do this I don't know only it's
just the left by the way I think that on
the right there's a tendency to do this
with regard to the American flag for
example I think most Americans are not
in favor of kneeling for the American
flag President Trump by injecting
himself into the American flag kneeling
situation he may be technically right
but he's also allowing a polarization
around a specific issue that's not good
for the country the left does this on
far less of an evidentiary basis than
Trump does about kneeling for the flag
the left picks cases like this Christine
Ford case where all we're saying is can
we see some more evidence and they say
well if you don't just believe the woman
it's because you don't care about sexual
assault if you don't just see and
believe here and believe and that means
you don't care enough about women
Matthew Dowd plays this game he says it
was despicable and outrageous what
happened to Anita Hill more than 25
years ago and a sexual predator was
given a lifetime seat on the Supreme
Court by the way never been proved that
Clarence Thomas is a sexual predator I
mentioned yesterday there are a lot of
holes in a Nita Hills story there are a
lot of holes in the time at the time and
Anita Hills story she originally wanted
to be anonymous before she came forward
once she came forward there are a bunch
of problems with her story including the
witnesses she talked to including the
fact that she called Clarence Thomas
many many times over many years after
the supposed incidents Matthew Dowd
doesn't care he just labels Clarence
Thomas a sexual predator
he said let's hope history doesn't
repeat itself in 2018 this is the
supposed conservative a day ABC and then
he continues and he says I don't know if
the allegations against Kavanagh are
true but keep in mind every high-profile
men accused of sexual abuse denies it
and has released a list of women saying
they're a good guy and each one turned
out to be an abuser so let me get this
straight
if you don't deny it
and you don't provide a list of
character witnesses you're guilty if you
do deny it and you provide a list of
character witnesses you're guilty this
is the Monty Python which test if we
throw her in the water and she's heavier
than a duck and she floats and she must
be a witch right that this is it how can
you have any semblance of justice under
these conditions how can you have any
semblance of sanity or certitude or
decency under these conditions and then
matthew dowd continually says enough
with the he-said she-said storyline if
this is he-said she-said
then let's believe the she in these
scenarios why why like really white
without any corroborate of evidence i
just are women inherently more
believable i don't like i don't i don't
understand the logic here
I thought the basis of feminism is that
men and women are to be treated exactly
the same way if that's the case then why
should we believe the woman over the man
if he denies and she says it happened
and there's no corroborate of evidence
well I need I'm more than willing to
believe her story if she can even
provide any corroborating evidence but
you're providing none and then saying we
should just believe the story she then
he says this is one of their favorite
things she has nothing to gain and
everything to lose
really she has nothing to gain what's
that book deal gonna be like at the end
of this story
what's the TV deal gonna be like at the
end of this story Anita Hill had
everything to gain Anita Hill is a
famous human she had an HBO full-on
movie made about her and Clarence Thomas
because supposedly he once said
something about a pubic hair on a coca
can hey this is it again this woman may
be telling the truth for the 1,000 and
first time during this program she may
be telling the truth but it is not true
to suggest that she has nothing to gain
and everything to lose
Matthew dad says for 250 years we have
believed that he in these scenarios
enough is enough really I didn't always
believe that he in these scenarios like
I think that Bill Clinton probably rape
ellonija Broderick I'm not believing
that he in these scenarios I think that
Roy Moore was preying on girls I got I I
think that Donald Trump has abused women
like I where is he getting this and the
answer he's getting this from nowhere
he's just looking for any sort of slim
read to hang his hat on here
this is gross stuff and again all of
this has to do with electoral politics
right now Republicans are having a tough
time in the
in polls the election polls show right
now the Democrats have the upper hand in
Arizona and Tennessee in the Senate
races
Kyrsten Sinema who is a real radical in
Arizona now has a slight lead over
martha mcsalley in the latest CNN poll
it shows that she is beating her by
seven points 50% to 43% in Tennessee
there's a candidate named Phil Bredesen
who is the former governor and he holds
a five-point edge over Marsha Blackburn
50% to 45 percent among likely voters
there yeah some of this has to do with
the President of the United States and
the fact is that bob Corker would still
be running in Tennessee if Donald Trump
hadn't basically destroyed him and in
Arizona President Trump has made himself
unpopular by attacking John McCain and
such so martha mcsalley is paying a
polling price but if arizona goes blue
and tennessee goes blue that is a bad
indicator that's a bad indicator right
now the chances that the Democrats take
the Senate are not horrendous they're
about the same as the chances that
Donald Trump was going to win the
presidency in 2016 according to 538 in
just a second I'm gonna discuss some of
those statistics and give you the latest
breakdown on the Senate and why
Democrats are so eager to vote plus
we'll talk about President Trump
revealing some new FISA documents and
stormy Daniels describing the
president's junk life hack dudes if you
don't want people who aren't your wife
describing your junk you probably
shouldn't show your junk to people who
aren't your wife really it's it's a life
hack the description I will say it made
me laugh I mean I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna lie about this and sure it's its
era of Yom Kippur sure it's the night
before the night of Yom Kippur but if I
can't get in a little bit of
dirty-minded frippery before the holiday
then you're under estimating maybe we'll
get to that in just one second but first
let's talk about saving money online
when you shop online G turn into a tab
holder like you're looking for promo
codes you're looking for the easiest way
to save money on a specific deal well
instead of that try honey honey is the
free browser add-on that over nine
million people are using every day to
save money while they shop online in two
clicks you can add honey to any browser
for free and then you shop like you
normally do honey scans and tests
millions of coupons in the background
and check out honey automatically
applies the best coupon so you're saving
money on an enormous number of deals
just because you decided to go and add
honey to your browser
now I've used honey on my browser at
Amazon it does work in Amazon I've used
it for deals like we got ourselves a
pressure cooker it's great I mean you
can save money just by using honey
there's no reason not to add it because
it doesn't cost you anything it's free
it takes two clicks to install it will
save you tons of money get honey for
free a join honey calm slash Ben again
that's join honey dot-com / Ben to start
saving with honey today Jo i-n honey
calm / Ben check it out right now and
start saving money there's no reason for
you to miss out also before we get to
the rest of the news and there is plenty
of it to come you're gonna have to go
and subscribe so go subscribe over at
daily wire comm $9.99 a month get to a
subscription today Lee Weyer comm when
you do you get the rest of this show
live you get the rest of Andrew Klavan
still live the rest of Michael moles is
awful still alive all of those things
live Plus today at 6:30 p.m. Eastern
3:30 p.m. Pacific do not miss our next
episode of daily wire backstage with
god-king jeremy boring me Andrew Klavan
Michael Noel's because that's still a
thing we do around here and Alicia Kraus
will be joined by special guests Glenn
Beck - Beck to talk about his new book
addicted to outrage which I have read
and his terrific we'll be taking
questions but only from our daily wired
subscribers so make sure to become one
today if you want to ask one a question
ask me a question ask Jeremy a question
if for some odd reason you want to ask
Noel's a question because you're high or
something you can do all that when you
go and subscribe again today 6:30 p.m.
Eastern 3:30 p.m. Pacific join us for
daily wire backstage with special guests
Glenn Beck become a subscriber to ask us
your questions right now also for $99
here you get all those things plus the
daily wire hot leftist here's hot or
cold tumblr I mean look at this thing so
much better than any mug any mug plus
I'm wearing pants go check it out right
now
the leftist here is hot or cold tumblr
and you get that for 99 dollars a year
you will indeed enjoy it so go check us
out plus we have another Sunday special
coming up to Sunday we are just a
content machine around here we have a
Sunday special coming up next Sunday
with a special guest whom I shall not
reveal to you at this point in time
you're going to have to wait and suffer
in silence but you can actually be
subscribed by going to youtube or itunes
and then you'll get it on Sunday go
check it out we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so the reason the Democrats trying to
hold off on Kavanagh as I've been saying
this entire time is because they're
hoping they win the Senate according to
538 many of the individual race forecast
in the 538 Senate model which launched
on Wednesday look pretty optimistic for
Democrats the model shows Manchin in
strong position to retain his seat in
West Virginia
it has Democrats as slight favorites to
win GOP seats in Nevada and Arizona
it thinks Democratic incumbents like
Claire McCaskill and Heidi Heitkamp
could close well down the stretch it
even gives bethe O'Rourke a credible
shot in Texas although Cruz remains the
favorite in that race right now 538
House forecast is there is a four and
five chance Democrats win control of
Congress a one in five chance that
Republicans keep control of Congress and
when you take a look at their Senate
forecast their Senate forecast basically
say that there is a two in three shot
that Republicans maintain the Senate but
there's a one in three shot that
Republican the Republicans lose the
Senate but 538 says the Senate model
basically suggests Republicans have
between a two and three and a seven in
ten chance to hold the Senate depending
on which version of their model they're
looking at that's because the Senate map
is really really bad for Democrats it's
about as unfavorable a map as any party
has faced in the Senate ever Democrats
have 26 seats up for election in
November Republicans have just 9/10 of
those 26 seats are in states Trump won
in 2016 including five states where he
won overwhelmingly so Democrats could
win the popular vote for the US House by
eight to nine percentage points and they
still would not win the Senate instead
they need about an 11-point advantage in
the House popular vote before they
become favorites to claim the Senate but
it's possible that Republicans could
lose the Senate and Democrats know this
and this is why they are attempting to
push this this vote off on Kavanagh as
long as humanly possible so the Tailwind
could be strong enough to carry them
also they're 11 seats that each party
has at least a 10 percent chance of
winning Arizona Florida Indiana Missouri
Mississippi Montana and North Dakota
Nevada Tennessee Texas and West Virginia
Democrats need eight of those eleven to
take the Senate so Democrats you know
have a have a micro path in a macro path
as 5:38 says and it is worth noting that
Democrats are highly motivated right now
if Republicans do not turn out to vote
they could lose the Senate and then
Trump has a Democratic Congress the last
two years of his first term which is a
disaster for president
he's gonna be fighting investigations at
every possible turn impeachment hearings
will probably be held things will get
very ugly very quickly consents the
Democrats are really mobilized in the
way the consents this is from people
like Charles Blow who has a piece titled
not to range determined the piece
spoiler alert is actually kind of
deranged it says they told us that we
suffered from trumped arrangement
syndrome this of course is in the New
York Times an emotional and illogical
obsession with opposing and unseating
Donald Trump they saw our principled
stand against corruption and criminality
against immorality and hatred has borne
of hyper partisanship and the bruises of
defeat they were unable to see that our
objection to Trump was an aiklen League
particular phenomenon that transcended
party tribalism and went to the core of
who we are as people and as a country
for us it was clear this man was wholly
unacceptable as a matter of character
and through patriotism demanded that we
say so without equivalent out
equivocation and unrelentingly and this
is the feeling that you get I mean I
live in California which means that you
see a lot of folks in California who
feel this way democratic turnout is
gonna be very high Republicans cannot be
sanguine Republicans have to turn out to
vote doesn't matter whether you like
Trump or not the only thing that matters
at this point is ensuring Republicans
keep the Senate if you do not want
emma-crats to hold the Supreme Court at
8:00 and then wait until Justice Anthony
Kennedy is replaced in 2021 by Justice
Elizabeth Warren right you gotta be very
worried about this if you are a
Republican or a conservative in any way
meanwhile President Trump is moving
forward with declassification of
documents related to the FISA warrant on
Carter page according to Politico and
I've been waiting the furthest for a
long time I keep saying why doesn't
Trump just release the documents if in
fact the FBI was wrongly surveilling
Carter page if in fact our nation's law
enforcement bodies were targeting the
Trump campaign Trump has the ability to
declassify all this and he should and he
should if he's got the goods let's see
the goods well it appears the Trump is
now moving toward the revelation of
those goods which I think adds some
credibility to his accusations here's
what Trump say here's what Politico says
about all of this president from moved
on Monday to immediately release a
tranche a former FBI director James
Comey 'he's text messages and
Declassified 20 pages of a surveillance
application the targeted former campaign
adviser
Carter page
Trump's latest offensive against a
Russia investigation that has ensnared
associates and has consumed his
attention for much of his presidency the
breadth of the order came as a surprise
and landed him in a full court White
House effort to shore up the Supreme
Court nomination of Judge Brett
Kavanaugh Trump demanded the FBI
produced twenty pages of the
surveillance application which
Republicans on Capitol Hill have
suggested would help show anti-trump
bias at the highest levels of the FBI
we're not gonna be able to actually
analyze how bad the Carter page FISA
warrant is until we actually see it but
the fact that Trump wants to reveal more
of it not less of it is an indicator
that at least he thinks that something
nefarious was going on Devin Nunez who's
been really pushing this at the house
Government Oversight Committee he says
that a shocking number of people have
bought the conspiracy theories and the
real conspiracy here is that the FBI was
basically targeting team Trump but you
are you are slowly starting to see this
collapse in on them even though the
mainstream media is not covering this
because they seem so focused on drinking
the Russian kool-aid on terms of what's
who's getting indicted by the special
counsel and instead focus on look was
there any collusion between the Trump
campaign and Russia which the answer is
no so okay so if will suits in the
documents and there's another case where
I'm gonna do the unpopular thing and say
I'm gonna wait to see the actual
documents before I jump to the FBI was
targeting Trump but the fact that Trump
wants to release more now less is an
indicator that at least he thinks he has
some of the goods on the so-called deep
state targeting him well in just a
second we're gonna talk about stormy
Daniels at long last and her accusations
in her new book because she's a feminist
here Owen let me tell you she is she is
just a hero for the ages we'll talk
about that in just one second so here is
stormy Daniels has a new book coming out
because you have to read a book by a
porn star I mean come on this is a woman
who has forged her way using nothing but
grit and her genitals toward the toward
the head of American public life is a
woman who was featured on Saturday Night
Live telling President Trump to step
down because she had consensual sex with
him a couple of times I mean just
amazing stuff from stormy generals so
the new book is called full disclosure
and it's now been obtained by the UK
Guardian which is the source of choice
for all left winners and basically the
Guardian acts as sort of a conduit for a
lot of left mu0
their prerogative it's a left-wing
newspaper in it Daniel's describes her
mounting disbelief has Trump began to
win primary contests in 2016 for the
Republican presidential nomination
former castmates whom she had not heard
from in years but who had heard her
story about sleeping with Trump in 2006
would call her up to marvel at the news
as Trump kept winning Daniels right she
began to think she might be in danger
and this is where she starts telling her
stories again about how she was
threatened in 2011 by somebody
associated with Trump and all the rest
of this again providing little to no
evidence that this ever happened she did
take a one hundred and thirty thousand
dollar payment from Team Trump to shut
up about it and then of course she's
getting a book deal so that'll be
lucrative for her she continued to
answer
Trump's many phone calls over the next
year after she had an affair with him
back in 2006 in hopes that he would make
good on his promise to put her on his
reality television show The Apprentice
Daniel writes Trump even suggested that
a cheat could be arranged to allow her
to survive through more episodes of the
show quote we'll figure out a way to get
you the challenges beforehand she quotes
him as saying and we can devise your
technique he was gonna have me cheat and
it was a hundred percent his idea ooh
ooh clearly he is the nefarious
character here not you the porn star who
had sex with a married man and then took
a hundred and thirty thousand dollars to
shut up about it and had sex with him in
the hopes that you'd get on TV clearly
the only bad character here is Trump now
listen this is not me defending Trump I
think Trump with regard to women is dirt
I think he's terrible with regards the
way he's treated women over the course
of his life but stormy Daniels is not a
nun hey stormy Daniels is not the
paragon of female virtue she's not even
the paragon of honesty come on and this
is ridiculous Trump has denied any I
love this she says whenever she saw
Trump on television four years after
where Daniels writes an internal
monologue would play out I had sex with
that I'd say to myself yeah
because but you did like I write this
was you you're not a victim lady
I mean you decided you were gonna have
sex with a married man because you don't
care about sex that much and because you
thought that would be worthwhile to get
on the apprentice and then there's the
part of the book that everybody cares
deeply about this is her first sexual
encounter with Donald Trump Trump's
bodyguard invites Daniels to dinner
which turns out to be an invitation to
Trump's penthouse she writes in a
description of alleged events that
Daniels has
clothes previously but which in the book
are printed with new and lurid detail
she describes Trump's genitals his penis
has quote smaller than average but not
freakishly small I'm so glad we're doing
this Daniels writes he knows he has an
unusual penis it has a huge mushroom
head like a toadstool all right and she
says I lay there a know that I was
getting bleeped by a guy with Yeti pubes
and a bleep like a mushroom character in
Mario Kart it may have been the least
impressive sex I'd ever had but clearly
he didn't share that opinion yeah so now
it's just she's trolling for Trump to
respond to all of this and you know I
wouldn't be surprised if Trump does
respond to all this he just has to
decide whether he looks more like Yoshi
or or baby luigi down there like I just
I don't understand I legitimately like
this is this is where we are and I look
forward to the point when we can be
asked about all this on stage we don't
have two presidents in my lifetime
who've had their penises described in
national publications right pot we now
know what what what Bill Clinton's penis
looked like according to Paula Jones but
we now know what Donald Trump's penis
looks like
according to stormy Daniels and all I
can say all I can say is that it might
be worthwhile for a guys to keep it in
their pants how about we start with that
life hack keep your junk in your pants
if you don't want people describing that
junk publicly I do love though that
storming Daniels is playing this is
though she was some sort of victim she
went there and she says you know Donald
promised me that I'd be on the
apprentice and Trump was probably like
right the apprentice that's what I call
my little guy I want to put you on the
apprentice it's also salacious and gross
but this is our politics this is the
game we have chosen this is the politics
we have chosen this is the business we
have chosen ah good times good times
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate and things
I hate will be combined with
deconstructing the culture today so
things I like on a much more serious
note tonight is Yom Kippur so after all
of that hilarity I'm gonna have to do a
bit of atonement this evening and
tomorrow and I'm gonna go from actually
the most ridiculous stuff to the most
serious stuff that ever happened there's
a book that I read over Rosh Hashanah
which is
history of the Warsaw Ghetto Uprising
and how I switch gears on this one is
beyond me but the book is called the
resistance by Israel Guttman who is the
the head of the yad vashem museum
dedicated to the Warsaw Ghetto Uprising
at least part of it and the book is sort
of a comprehensive look at what happened
during the Warsaw Ghetto Uprising of
1943 one of the great kind of heroic
Jewish stories of all time the Nazis had
shipped off the Warsaw Ghetto was in and
of itself an enormous human rights
violation basically four hundred
thousand Jews were shipped into an area
one mile square they were they were put
nine into a room they were allotted 143
calories a person by the Nazis the Nazis
basically wanted to starve them to death
and then when the final solution was
decided upon they started shipping all
of these folks to Auschwitz after the
first shipment to Auschwitz a group of
Jews knowing they're gonna die anyway
formed a resistance with pretty much no
arms and they proceeded to hold off the
Germans for weeks on end all the way
from April 1919 and 43 into mid-may they
held off the German army it's a pretty
amazing story you can check it out
Israel Gutman's the resistance there's
also a pretty good movie that was made
about this called uprising with about
with I think Hank Azaria and Donald
Sutherland and leelee sobieski I think
the internet legally sobieski the the
actress she's quite good it's it's a
good movie so check that out as well
it's real Guttman's resistance okay time
for some things that I hate so one of
the things that's very difficult about
the Internet is that so many memes go
around you're never sure what's real or
not so there's a meme that was going
around of Anderson Cooper standing in
really deep water while his producer
stood above him with a camera and we
were supposed to believe that Anderson
Cooper was sort of faking it that the
the it was from Hurricane Ike in 2008 I
believe and the implication was the
Anderson Cooper was faking the footage
that the water wasn't really all that
deep and this followed on the heels of a
lot of video from the current hurricane
where you'd see like a weather person
standing in front trying to brace
against the wind then two dudes walking
in the background like there was no big
deal happening well the problem is that
if you're gonna actually make those
sorts of accusations you probably should
back them up Anderson Cooper rightly is
ticked off about this he says that
entire segments
was about how there are ditches
underwater and that you can be walking
along and not spot the ditch and go
plunging right into the ditch here's
Anderson Cooper explaining now over the
weekend however the son of the president
Donny jr. tweeted out this picture of me
and waist-high water my camera crew a
few feet away on higher ground in only a
little bit of water
Donny jr. was claiming it showed me in
Florence faking the depths of flood
waters in order to somehow harm his
father and I quote from his tweet stop
lying to try to make at real Donald
Trump look bad
he wrote now look I don't expect the
president's son to ever admit he was
wrong or one of the president's former
advisors or frankly anyone else who's
retweeted these pictures but I at least
thought that they and you should know
the truth okay and he's not wrong to be
upset about that I will say that nowhere
in that tweet from Donald Trump jr. does
he actually accused Cooper of doing this
during the current hurricane but the
level vagary in the tweet is not a great
thing and people should be careful about
what they tweet you know we all make
mistakes on Twitter cuz everything moves
too fast here it's sort of retweet what
comes across your page but if you're
gonna make those sorts of accusations
you ought to be clearer about it okay so
meanwhile the Emmys happened last night
and I'm not sure that anybody actually
watched the Emmys I'm not sure what the
ratings were like I can't imagine they
were great but it was typical Hollywood
leftist culture and as I've said many
times what we have right now in America
is a cultural divide that is reflecting
itself in politics the left has taken
the commanding heights and culture and
the right responds by taking the
commanding heights and politics they say
you guys want to come for our guns you
call us better clingers you call us to
pleura bowls you call us all sorts of
names and you know what we're gonna do
we're gonna protect ourselves by
ensuring that our politicians don't
agree with you well that was underscored
last night by just more politicking from
the Emmys stage because they can't just
give awards to people on the basis of
non politics they have to talk politics
naturally last-man-standing was
cancelled by ABC and then picked up by
Fox right which is great that's right
and Roseanne was cancelled by herself
but picked up by white nationalists all
you know I heard Roseanne is actually
moving to Israel Wow I mean damn how
messed up is your life when you have to
go to the Middle East just to get peace
of mind okay now that that last joke is
particularly stupid because Israel is
actually a pretty good place to live in
Israel how many of these folks in
Hollywood have said that they want to
pick up and move to Canada just because
Trump had was elected in the first place
that's a that's a really dumb point also
ripping on Roseanne is sort of like your
chief rip you know that she's picked up
by white nationalists meanwhile half the
people in the audience are engaged in
sins various and sundry is a little bit
absurd but that wasn't the extent of it
the red carpet was replete with people
in Hollywood virtue signaling for the
SJW crowd I am wearing Nike to applaud
them for supporting Colin Kaepernick and
his protest against racial injustice and
police brutality these are not dark
times these are awakening times and we
all have to wake up you can say
something to Colin right now what would
it be
Thank You Colin thank you for all that
you do thank you for being brave thank
you for being courageous thank you for
taking Anita thank you for making
millions of dollars from a massive
multinational corporation that uses
cheap labor from abroad just that people
can posture on red carpets well done
Hollywood well done Hollywood can't
imagine why anybody wouldn't trust you
with the future of the country and the
left doesn't understand that when they
they insult the rest of the country
culturally the country responds by
putting people in power who they think
will protect them from Hollywood you
want to know what makes people in the
middle of the country feel threatened
the idea that folks on the Emmy stage
will one day be in the halls of power
again governing them that's what scares
people in the middle of the country and
and rightly so okay final thing that I
hate this is so Thandie Newton was also
at the Emmys and she had to drop this
line it is very important to virtue
signal about feminism and atheism at the
same time from the stage so Santana
Newton won an award for Westworld she
was quite good in Westworld she's a
terrific actress but here's what she had
to say after winning Tandy
[Applause]
I don't even believe in God but I'm
gonna thank her tonight oh well I don't
even believe in the Emmys but I'm going
to laugh at them right now
because like why do we possibly care
what Thandie Newton thinks about God
well the sort of disparaging remark that
God is only God if if God is a woman and
when we did this with ariana grande who
did a song the same way and it was God
as a woman but God was apparently a very
highly sexualized woman performing for
the pleasure of men's that was weird but
again this sort of cultural sneering is
is not going to be to Hollywood's
benefit and I think that they haven't
paid the price for it yet but they will
at some point in the future speaking of
which Sir Paul McCartney has a new song
ripping president Trump as well his new
song talks about how terrible President
Trump is the song is called despite
repeated warnings and it contains this
jab against President Trump
can we do
what can I do
[Music]
a spoon
so I think the Beatles are the most
overrated band in history but this is
much worse than the Beatles
okay Paul McCartney on his own is much
worse than the Beatles it's just a bad
song and also this kind of blunderbuss
approach this man is bound to lose his
ship and his crew self-righteousness
from people who can't read music is
always weird to me like that just the
musical self-righteousness of these
folks again there are lots of reasons to
criticize president Trump but our
cultural better is informing us why
President Trump ought not be trusted on
politics when all assumed problem
McCartney knows about music somewhat but
I'm not going to assume he knows much
about politics just because he writes
songs like that I'm not sure from that
song he knows much about music because
the song sucks okay well we will be back
here not tomorrow because tomorrow is
Yom Kippur we will be back here on
Thursday with all of the latest I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018